if you're still playing rocket League  and you want to get even better the next  update is just for you I'm Tony and this  is your high-flying gamespot news update  rocket leagues next update includes a  custom training mode this lets you pick  the arena your position on the field and  even the direct path of the ball it's  the perfect way to practice shots are  saves whether they're on the ground in  the air or off the walls you can even  upload these sequences for other players  to try and a new tab will track which  uploads are the most popular on your  platform if you're not a pro already  this update will certainly help custom  training is one of many updates that  have come to rocket League including new  cars and even new sports like hockey and  basketball and it won't be the last  update either the team at psionic says  this is just the beginning so to stay up  to date with everything they're doing  you're already in the right place  you